via valen on sir Ostara he beated Surak
via phone sv that sir this is normal
alpha he's anti-immigration anti-eu and
anti-islam and he could be Austria's
next president when Hoffa began
campaigning a year ago the odds of
brexit below a new dawn and a donald
trump presidency that was a fanciful
idea the world's a different place now
anything is possible and austria's
presidential election is a test of
European support right-wing populism in
the new era oh she looks like a very
moderate politician and comes off very
mainstream that's bloomberg's Jonathan
Tyrone we spend time with Xhosa on the
campaign trail when he's surrounded by
my groups of his freedom party
supporters that's when the conversation
gets a little bit interesting void being
saucy insane oh then start the Subaru so
is this softly-spoken career politician
a wolf in sheep's clothing you're not
being well calling you
did I'm not I'm another dangerous person
of course forty-five-year-old hofer has
moved his freedom party from the
far-right fringe of Austrian politics to
the mainstream the situation inside
Austria is bolstering his support the
countries at the front line of Europe's
refugee crisis last year applications
for asylum in Austria skyrocketed to
nearly 90,000 at the same time
unemployment is rising hitting a high of
over six percent this year people are
voting for hofer because they're
frustrated and they're scared and they
feel left out and they want to vote for
somebody who's a protest this
presidential election is a rerun
Austria's Constitutional Court
overturned the results of the May ballot
historically the post of President is
ceremonial the real power lies with the
Chancellor but HOFers threatened to push
his authority to the limit if he wins
Bopha would become Western Europe's
first democratically elected right-wing
nationalist head of state since the
Second World War